PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your Cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka.
And in this episode,
we'll share the recipe
to plan a hot DR pattern
for your application
that's deployed on-premise.
So, let's dive in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A little recap-- in
the last two episodes,
we talked about Mane Street Art,
that runs their applications
on-premise and are building a DR
infrastructure on Google Cloud.
This started with a cold DR plan
and moved to a warm standby,
due to the need for
lower RTO and RPO values.
Well, now, Mane Street Art
has become really popular
and cannot afford to be
down, even for seconds.
Since their requirement is to
achieve a near-zero RTO and RPO
appeal values, the only way
is by running HA architecture
across their production
environment and Google Cloud
concurrently.
Let's see how this works
from the setup perspective.
We create a VPC network.
Then we configure
the connectivity
between the on-premise network
and the Google Cloud network.
We create custom
images of the servers
in Google Cloud with the
exact same configuration
as on-premise.
Then, configure the replication
between on-premise database
server and the one
on Google Cloud.
Remember, that if your
database systems permit
only a single rateable database
instance when you configure
replication, then you
might need to ensure
that one of the
database replicas act
as a read-only server.
Create individual
instance templates
that use the images for the
application server and the web
server.
Configure regional
managed instance groups
for the application
and web servers.
Then configure health checks
using Stackdriver monitoring
and load balancing
using the regional
managed instance groups.
Configure a scheduled a task
to create regular snapshots
of the persistent disk.
And lastly, configure
the DNS service
to distribute traffic between
your on-premise environment
and the Google
Cloud environment.
With this hybrid
approach, you need
to use a DNS service that
supports weighted routing
to the two production
environments
so that you can serve the
same application from both.
In case of a failure
on premise, you just
disable the DNS routing to
the on-premise web server,
and that's it.
In most cases, the DNS
service supports health checks
and will automatically route all
the traffic to the LD servers
on Google Cloud.
And when it is all
back to normal,
and can handle
production traffic,
we need to resynchronize
the databases.
If your database system
doesn't automatically
promote a read-only replica
to be the rateable primary
on failure, you need
to intervene to ensure
that the replica is promoted.
After ensuring that, just
enable the DNS routing back
to distribute traffic to both
on-premise and Google Cloud.
Well, there you have it.
If you are running your
application on premise
and are looking to
achieve very, very small
RTO and RPO values,
then hopefully you'll
learn how to approach recovering
the environment from failure
using Google Cloud hot HA
across the two environments.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Here's hoping you're cooking
up your own DR strategy.
Join us next time
and learn the recipe
to implement disaster
recovery for applications
that are built on Google Cloud.
If you like this video and would
like to see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]